the light in this compound can only stay
on for a short while enough time for
people here to cook clean and prepare
for the evening for many families in
Ghana it costs too much to keep the
lights on any longer electricity prices
increased to 18 percent in May this
governments don't really care about what
we feel the only thing they think about
is their comfortability because if this
government really cares about the people
of this country
I mean they wouldn't be taxing us this
much
rationing power means having to manage
in the dark it's yet another headache
for ghanaians already struggling with a
High Cost of Living inflation and tax
increases
government leaders hope a new three-year
billion dollar bailout agreement with
the international monetary fund will
turn around the economy
Ghana has one of the biggest economies
in West Africa more than 50 percent of
electricity here is generated by
independent companies if they don't get
paid on time production will be affected
but the state owes more than a billion
dollars to Independent power producers
it's a lot of money in a country
suffering its worst economic crisis in a
generation now threatened with the
possibility of power Cuts we may not be
able to Guarantee Supply as we're
supposed to do we need to pay for our
Opex our capex
and other commitment obligations that we
have to our external parties like the
lenders and creditors so we are
definitely not in position to Guarantee
Supply
the ins conditions for the bailout means
the government has to cut public
spending and increase taxes
so ghanaians will likely soon pay even
more for their electricity to stay
connected haramatasa Al Jazeera Accra